hey folks welcome to type safegraphql
with typescript
my name's aaron powell and i'm a
principal cloud advocate at microsoft
over the last 15 or so years i've been
doing web development
starting with languages like classic asp
and php through to.net
compiled languages on the server and
then eventually to
javascript on the server and javascript
in the client in my time i've
been building web applications i've seen
all sorts of different ways we can do
data access whether it's just normal
page refreshes and getting more data on
request to custom built apis to serve
out you know kind of like
ajax's sort of endpoints for an
application
through to really strict rest
implementations but today i want to talk
about specifically graphql
which is another way which we can do
dire access if you want to get in touch
with me after the session
you'll find all my details here on the
slides and uh do feel free to reach out
if you've got any questions that i don't
get a chance to cover off in the q a
i'll do my best to answer them after the
session if i
uh or at least help you along the way of
finding the answers if i don't know them
myself
but that's enough about me you're here
not to learn about me and my background
my history
you're here to learn about graphql and
typescript and how we can work with
those together
but before we get into looking at how we
can build an application i want to talk
a bit about what graphql is
and why it's interesting graphql was
originally created by facebook
as a query language for doing client and
server in your actions
it's not how you implement a server or
it's not a client implementation
but it's more a specification of how
those two can talk to each other
so you still build a server
implementation whether it's in
javascript
net node python etc we can build
whatever we need for the kinds of
applications we're building
and then we can build a client that's
also going to be able to talk over the
same protocol
generate the kinds of queries that are
expected and send them to the server
so what makes graphql different to rest
because rest is the most common way that
people have built apis in
at least in the past well the main
difference is that rest is very
centered around the way the server
visualizes its data and wants to expose
that out
let's say we're building a trivia
application and inside of that we're
going to have
made three primary model types we've got
our game we've got players and we've got
questions
now in a rest scenario at least in a
very strict approach to doing rest
probably have a game endpoint so slash
api game
and then from that we can get back uh an
ap a game
based off its id and then from that we
would have an array of ids of
questions and players that we then have
to follow it through and then do
additional requests to get all that
information
now this might be a little bit over uh
complex for
some scenarios where you are fetching
data but it's also going to be ideal for
others
i'm not here to tell you that you should
be using graphql or rest in
your current applications you've got to
work out that one on yourself on your
own
depending on the kinds of applications
you're building graphql though
is a kind of the flipped model for
compared to rest
so where rest is all about what the
server defines how you do your data
access
graphql is more about how the client
wants to be able to get data
you still expose the data models that
your server has available to it
but it is up to the client to determine
how it wants to query for that data
and then to build other queries that are
going to be right for the particular
request that it needs to be doing
and for the data it needs at that point
in time now this can avoid
scenarios where you're over fetching
data getting data that you don't
actually need at that point in time
because
you're trying to say just display the
the high score board at the end of the
trivia game
or maybe you don't need all the
questions but you unfortunately might
have to get those
if the depending on how the rest model
is set up in graphql you can be a lot
more selective about that and only get
the data that you need
but as i said i'm not here to tell you
exactly when to use rest versus graphql
i'm here to look at the specific
scenarios of how we can do type safety
with graphql
so why is type safety with graphql a
topic of conversation
well with the graphql schema that we can
build out it's going to be type safe
we define strongly typed data models and
the fields that are available inside of
those data models
we then define strongly types queries
and mutations so how we can get data and
how we can change data
that are available inside of our our
server and for our clients to
communicate on
so having this type information
originally to start with is a good
building block for building a type safe
application
but with javascript well we can lose a
lot of that site safety anyway because
javascript is an inherently untyped
language
that's where typescript can come to play
so what are we going to be building
today
well we're going to be building an
application with two components we're
going to start with the server
and for that server i'm going to be
using the apollo graphql framework
so this is a server implementation of
graphql that can run in a variety of
different manners whether it's on a web
server platform like express or cover
or you can run it in a serverless model
which i'm going to be using azure
functions to do
i just like the serverless model but
it's the same approach whether you're
doing a
a server or a serverless model or
whether you're using any of the
different
underlying providers that apollo
supports
and then from a client standpoint well
we're going to need a client that's
going to connect to that and i'm going
to be building a react-based web
application
now the stuff that i'm covering up here
isn't exclusively supported by
react it could be applied to any of the
other javascript frameworks you might be
using whether it's felt
angular view et cetera i just prefer
react because it's the one that i've
had the most experience with and it's
kind of my my go-to approach with doing
web applications
but like i said it's entirely up to you
um how you want to do the client
and the stuff i will be showing you is
applicable to pretty much every
javascript framework
but as i said we want to do end-to-end
type safety so that's where typescript
is going to come into play
i'm going to be using typescript as a
way to model out our
backend and also do strongly type
front-ends but what i want is the type
information i have in my graphql schema
available on both client and server so
they are literally talking the same
language
so let's jump out of the slides and have
a look at how we can do that with a bit
of a demo
i'm going to go through a subset of a
larger workshop that i've got
share the link to that at the end if
you're interested and we're going to be
building out a couple of different
pieces that look at the specific type
safe aspects of building a graphql
server
so here we are in vs code and it's time
to get started
i said this is a workshop where i've
already got some of the stuff set up
and here is a graphql schema that i've
predefined
as we can see i've got a number of types
that are available i have a question
type
a game that game has questions available
to it so we've got types that reference
other types that we have
i have some enums and if we scroll down
a little bit further
we'll see that we have a query so this
is the entry point when someone is doing
a request against a refql
uh server and these are the things that
you're able to do against it you're able
to get back again by its id
you have to get back all the games in
the system and you're able to get back
a player's results for a particular game
so there are answers so we can work out
how many they got correct and versus how
many they got incorrect
what we're going to need to do is we're
going to need to implement some
resolvers that work with these
so resolvers are functions that handle
the queries or handle
the graphql objects as they're being
parsed through
so let's pop over to another file called
resolvers.ts
i'm going to put the schema on the side
here so inside of resolvers
i'm going to start building out those
queries that i've got here on the side
and
functions that handle those so in my
resolver i have query which is a type
name that matches the same type that i
had inside of my schema
and let's start with the easiest one
which is game
so sorry games because we just want to
get all the games and well
i need to return something but this is
just an object that i've created it
doesn't understand any type of
information it's got no correlation to
the type of information that we have
with inside of our schema
but because i've worked with the poly
before i know that the first argument is
going to be the
parent of this in the object graph but
this is a root entry point for a graphql
schema
so i don't have a parent at this point
any arguments that could be provided to
this operation
i don't have any arguments at this point
in time because games doesn't take any
arguments
and then finally i have a context where
i can provide
something oh i can get access to like
services that have been injected
and other stuff that are available for
the lifetime of this request
one of those things is data sources and
that's going to give me access to my
underlying database
now i know that that's there because
i've implemented this application and
i've
i know the code base so i know what's
there but i don't have any type
information
i don't know that if i do data sources
that there are any fields of this i
could access
having worked on this code base i know
that i can do game which is a property
available there and i can get games
off that and i know that's going to
return something that can be handled by
graphql
similarly if i want to implement the
games uh
the the gauge resolver uh so i do game
and then again we don't have a parent
i know that the second argument will
have uh objects
an object which is the arguments that
are provided by um the query and
i can decompose this with the id and
finally i can get data sources again
and i know that i can return data
sources game.getgame
and file with the id but again i only
know this information because
i built the code base myself if we have
a look at any
this it's all just untyped i have my nes
everywhere and
well now typescript really isn't giving
me any value so
i need to work out how can we get some
of that schema value schema typed
information
here to make touchscript giving us some
actual value or i just throw away
typescript
those are kind of the two endpoints that
i've got here
we'll jump through to a slightly more
completed version of the application
and have a look at that let's open up
the resolves again
and we'll see that i've gone through and
i've got the same results
for game and games i also have my player
results so this is how i can get back
the
results that a player has submitted so
their answers
and we'll see again we're decomposing a
couple of um fields out of there and
without having the schema side by side
do i know that it's game id and player
id
i i'm going to assume they are because
that's what i
i wrote previously in uh in the demo
before i started um
but you know if you didn't have that
scheme like immediately available it's
it's a little bit opaque we don't know
what's there
well so this is an async function so
we're awaiting on
the get game method on our game data
source
but did we realize that that was
something that returned a promise by
looking at it
previously no we didn't we know that
because we know this code base and we
can dig through it
so this is where we want to start
looking at how we can get that type safe
information
i'm going to install a new package whoop
install there it is
i called graphql code gen cli so graphql
code gen is a series of packages
for generating code from graphql
and this is a command line tool that
will then allow me to generate out
the um the typescript definitions that i
need
so let's run npx
graphql code gen in it and it's going to
prompt us through a bit of a wizard on
what we want
we want to build a back-end or api
server the schema is at slash graphql
schema dot graphql graph
ql there we go uh we want to generate
the typescript model definitions
and we also want to generate the
typescript resolver definitions so we
can strongly type our resolvers
uh we want to output this to say graph
dot slash graph
ql slash generated dot ts
uh we generate an introspection file so
that's just some debugging information
we'll leave the default yaml file name
and we're going to add a
npm run script called gen that will be
so that we can just run the code
generator
without having to do npx every single
time so this is now going to go ahead
and
it's going to create us our yaml file
for our config
it's going to then update our package
json with that new run script and with
some additional dependencies that we're
going to need
and basically get our environment ready
so that we can go ahead and build our
graphql
um our strongly typed information from
our graphql schema file
all right so if we do npm npm run gen
we'll see that that's gone ahead and
done it oh and it looks like
i have got an error in something that
i've added and
i forgot to install my dependencies oops
npm install
because it added some new things to my
package json and i completely forgot to
do an npm install to make sure that they
are installed as well so
that's just uh the joys of live demo is
you've got to remember all the steps
that you meant to run
npm run gen we'll do that again
take two and excellent that's worked
successfully
let's close off our terminal have a look
and here is our new generated file so
this has got a whole bunch of
typescript type definitions we'll see
that we've got question here
and if we were to pop open our schema on
the side
go back to generated we'll see that
that's what the same feels we have an id
which is an id type
which is using the scalar type of id
we'll see that we've got
our um our question correct answer and
answers which are strings or arrays of
strings
we'll see a bit further down we have
game which has
scalar types and then it's got some like
some optional type so the game state is
an optional value
or we've got arrays which have got
player and questions so on and so forth
you kind of get the idea of where i'm
going here
one-to-one mapping between what our
schema had
what that does mean is that i can come
into my resolver function you know file
here
and then i can say that i want to
strongly type this as resolvers
resolvers resolvers
there we go and that's going to come
from api graphical generator so this
will import that in and now
we'll see that say the id is stronger
type to string
fantastic because we know that that is
of our schema
coming in as a string id and we know
that that's
correct excellent so we can we know that
that's there we know that same with
player id
is going to be all correct we know that
the player results needs to return a
particular type and so on and so forth
so
we're getting some of that type safe
information
we still don't know what our data source
is though which is a little bit of a
problem because well
is it game or is it games i i'd have to
dig through my own code base to remember
um you know it's the kind of thing that
you don't hit to run time
but let's just do an npm start kick off
our api and have a look at what's
actually up and running
now we'll give this a moment it's going
to compile our typescript and
there we go that's all up and running
we'll start our local web server here we
go here's our graphql endpoint
and we'll zoom that in once it loads
excellent uh this load up the graphql
playground
and we'll see that excellent we can
perform a query
and here's a query that i've previously
done so it's just going to dump out all
the games
the state of the game its id and the
questions that were asked
so if you hit run on this um it turns
out that we get another error
and you think that even if you're doing
a pre-recorded talk you wouldn't have
run time errors and stuff like that you
should get those in anything
but no this is actually an area that i
expect what it's saying is it can't
return null from a non-null field
question.correct answer well that's
because
what we're doing is well actually let's
just jump back to v's code and we'll
have a look at that
close off our terminal and we'll see
that in our schema
if we go up to the top we have correct
answer
but if we were to go through to data
slash
type so this is the definition of our
our database so this is our databases
the way our database visualizes types
well we'll see that
we actually store correct underscore
answer not correct
answer as pascal case and similarly we
have
incorrect answers not answers in array
so the way that the schema is exposing
stuff doesn't 100
map to what our database is because we
don't want to expose our database
directly
and we are doing a bit of translation so
we need to do something that tells us
well
that these two models need to map back
and forth between each other as well
something that we're currently not doing
and for that we can add some model
mapping
inside of our code gen file
so let's open up our cogen yaml
and we're going to add some model
mappers
actually we'll jump across and i'll show
this in a completed version
rather than uh rather than potentially
running doing some more runtime errors
we're running out of time for today
so let's try and get things working as
much as we can
let's come into api
go gen.yaml and if we have a look here
i've generated i've configured my
code generator so it's got some context
come back to that in a moment
but most importantly we have mappers
this mapper is saying when you find a
graphql type of question
we're going to use our graph question
model type which is defined in
typescript
if we do npm run gen here
uh npm i am in the wrong folder
where are we where are we going we are
going to
uh completed api there we go
and npm run gen so we'll just generate
out our
[Music]
typescript file excellent that'll be
ready in just a minute there we go
and if we have a graphql generated now
we have a bit of additional information
that's mapping between
our our questions and our players
because what it's doing is it's
detecting that whenever it finds a
question it's going to return a question
model
so how does this work with inside of our
resolver
well now our resolver function is going
to return a type of
this this is returning a game model
which is expected here
or player results is going to return a
different kind of model
and we're then going to map those a bit
further down with
our our object mappers with inside of
our resolver
so here it's saying if you find a
question so this is the type that you
need to return from graphql
we're going to receive a question model
so that's its parent this time
and then from that we're going to
generate a new thing which is going to
return an array of strings
so we're going to take the incorrect
answers the correct answer
and then return that out similarly with
a correct answer we're just going to
return
the correct underscore answer field from
the question
model so now if i change my underlying
data structure
so inside of my database it's only
called correct answer i change it to
correct answer with you know
with a pascal case well then this will
start being a
compilation error because this field no
longer exists and then i know that i
could remove
this bit of code because i no longer
need to do that custom mapping
so this type end-to-end type safety is
going all the way from our underlying
database
through to what our schema has defined
and then we're having our resolver the
thing that works
to kind of merge those two together
understand that type safety
the other thing that i'm doing here is
well i want my client application my
react application to also work with
this type information so if i come down
into
my touchscreen application i have say
a page where we're going to create a new
game so this is going to need to perform
a mutation
against our graphql server so it's going
to need to create a new game
so what i've done is i've created a
reusable
little bit of graphql a little graphql
query that's really useful called great
game
that is just the mutation great game and
this is what it's going to do and it's
going to return me the game id
i don't need all the other fields i
don't need the questions at this point
in time
because i only need the id to go through
to the next screen
inside of my config yaml file for
so my code gen yaml file for graphical
code generator
i've also said that i've got to generate
a tsx file
which is going to contain some react
hooks
and it's going to use the typescript
plugin as a type operations plugin so
it's going to load
these files these operation files here
so these are those pre-written
queries and mutations and then it's
going to generate me a typed document
node
so this is going to so this could
generate me specific react
uh hooks if i wanted them as react hooks
or pyrolytic components and things like
that
but i've told it that i'm not going to
use those plugins at this point in time
instead i'm just going to return typed
document nodes so these document nodes
can be loaded by
anything that's going to be consuming
graphql uh whether it's
react or angular or spelt etc i'm just
i said so happen to be doing this with
react
so this create dot game document is the
thing that's been code generated for me
i can then pass this to a used mutation
which is
from the apollo client for our graphql
so this is a
custom react hook that apollo has given
us um i also have just
some state some normal like react state
that's available to me as well
that i'm putting some type information
in that i'm putting some objects in
and these i'm combining together to
create a strongly typed version of
um a query against our graphql server
so i have my create game operation
that's here that when executed
so depending on when an effect is traded
so someone has clicked the button to
actually create the game
it's going to call that hook which is
going to perform some operations
eventually we'll get back some data
and that data is going to have if we
have a look at that getting unpacked
here we go
down here on line 21 that gets unpacked
we're not loading and we've called and
there wasn't an error and we received
the create game response then i know
that i have
an id field here which is going to be a
stream which is the value that i get
back from performing that mutation
against my graphql server so this might
seem
kind of a lot of parts that are all
connected together but it all comes down
to relying on
the code that i'm generating out of here
looking at
a schema that i've got here combining
that with some
pre-written commands and operations that
i've got with inside of my graphql
application
so the client has some pre-written
operations working with a schema that
i've got elsewhere
and we're using the types end-to-end
across those so that i can generate out
type safe
resolvers so these are the resolvers
that are going to be returning
custom model mappers so that i can map
the underlying data structures of my
database
through to the types that my schema says
are available to the clients and
eventually have a client
that is capable of using these
operations
generating some type information of them
and then when
say a mutation is called i get the data
back and i get that
data back in a tight way that i can have
that field available to me
and i know what it is and i can i can
perform the correct step
through in my application to get to the
next point
so i know that i was a real lot of
information that we covered in a very
short period of time
but i hope it gives you an idea of how
you can do
type-safe end-to-end graphql
applications
we looked at a subset of a workshop that
i've got um
there's about eight different modules in
that workshop that cover off how to
build a graphql application with
typescript
um all the way from the first setting up
of the server
through to how we do that uh end-to-end
type safety with a react application
talking through to the graphql server
back end um so
the links there on the slide if you want
to go check that out and have a bit more
of a poke around
in the code that was used inside of this
demo
the way that i approached this was using
graphql code genre
i like to go schema first in the way
that i build out my typescript
sorry my graphql servers so i tend to
generate a graphql schema file and then
want to export that as type information
but there are other ways if you wanted
to do more of
use the typescript objects that you're
creating so like classes and things like
that
and then use that to generate a graphql
schema from it so kind of go the other
way
or and so there's there are projects out
there that will do that
um that i haven't played around with
much
um but yeah if you prefer to do more of
a um
a code first approach rather than a
schema first approach
you can definitely tackle it in that
regards if you're wanting to learn a bit
more about how you can run graphql on
azure um
there's a link to a blog series that
i've been writing that looks at all the
different aspects of how we can
do things like well actually taking this
workshop that i've got here
how you can run that kind of a code base
inside of azure as well as how you can
run things
on a server infrastructure rather than a
service approach
but that's all that i had time for today
and all i wanted to cover off
thank you for uh sticking around for the
session thank you for
letting me present some of my learnings
that i've had when building
strongly typed graphql applications
i hope it's been interesting i hope
you've learned something and i hope that
it shows you that it is definitely
possible
to use the type of information we've got
in graphql with
a server and a client all together so we
can do end-to-end type safety
bye for now